and here's to you Rick SOI give me one
sec as you guys know yesterday my video
got taken down for a ridiculous reason
of a pure day hopefully it's gonna come
back when it comes back I'm gonna share
it it got nearly 40,000 views yet within
like 10 to 12 hours it today would have
easy reach 200,000 views in Charlotte
and it's will inshallah once it comes
out we'll get you guys in Charlotte to
share it now what they do is they
release a video and check this out look
where they start the video and they cut
all of it where I greet her and say hi
Jada how you doing you okay
they don't want the bridge problem to
see how we Muslims are really like they
cut that bit out
yeah that's point one they cut that bit
out here and then you know what they do
you know what they do look it's what
they do
this is where she goes on a tantrum and
this is where she goes on a mad one
because I because I challenged her yet
and because she couldn't answer and she
was looking silly what'd she do this she
got a security and look what and the way
they cut it look they've got exactly
where I was at where you going why was
it off come this talk
this is where they cut it and you can
see the games they're playing and funny
thing of yesterday my movie is taking
now and today they're sharing this cut
version so what we're gonna do guys
hopefully when the video comes back out
share it because we have the uncut
version and expose these people for what
they are and date of things I'm not
gonna come across again I'm gonna come
across you again one way or another but
anyways the point here is when the video
comes out hopefully you can see the
uncut version for those who haven't seen
it and make sure you share it everywhere
and let people see their true face